at least 40 million Americans are under
threat of severe weather this morning
nine tornadoes were reported in Kansas
Missouri and Oklahoma yesterday some
straight-line wind gusts exceeded 100
miles an hour
tornadoes damaging wind and heavy rain
are possible from the central us into
the Northeast today Tony - copal is in
Raytown Missouri near Kansas City with
some of the damage Tony good morning
good morning take a look at this a
massive red oak tree survived here for
200 years but didn't survive
this storm and if you peek through the
branches that white there that's
actually part of a house and in fact the
bedroom fortunately no one was injured
in this storm but residents in the area
are bracing for another day of dangerous
weather the house shook and the windows
like blew open I didn't at the time even
though like if the whole house was
coming down we had heard the tornado
sirens go off so I wasn't sure if it was
just the tree or if it was something
bigger the same scene played out near
Elkhart Indiana where a fierce winds
sent a tree tearing into this home
sirens warned residents to take shelter
in Oklahoma where ominous clouds brought
up nursing rain and damaging tornadoes
at least nine were reported in Oklahoma
Kansas and Missouri just one day after
more than 18 tornadoes ripped through
the Midwest including this twister in
tesco Kansas
across the central US heavy rain
lightning and strong winds tore through
homes and knocked down power lines and
Langdon Kansas a bolt of lightning set
this oil tank on fire and as far north
as Chicago heavy winds damaged buildings
including ripping the roof off this
apartment complex
we have no top of the building are at
the top of the building it's gone and
the most severe weather today is
expected between here in Kansas City and
Des Moines Iowa that could mean hail
that could mean tornadoes it could also
mean more straight-line wind residents
are hoping they don't top yesterday's
high of a hundred and six miles per hour
Anthony well incredible scene there Tony
thanks